and you're here coming to our da table
with I don't know what intention telling
me about
ISL well they d right you should
apologize me because he has the money he
can he can marry four wives do you see
the corruption in America there is no
corruption you should focus on Zionism
because PornHub only finds these
degenerate things that leure men like
you in yes single men pornography or
watch pornography I have watched
pornography do you think that's good for
you do you think a grown man
masturbating pornography is a good thing
I me I'd rather be having sex anyways
let's do some how many people watch
you're a terrorist thank you very much
alhamdulillah
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him said
Sak gets in the way of Calamity brothers
and sisters your sodak is a ban for you
it is a witness for you wouldn't it be
amazing for you to support people in
Turkey Syria Pakistan Afghanistan
Palestine and many other places around
the world with one umah where they are
helping those who have been afflicted by
floods by War by earthquakes donate now
brother and sister inah and get your SAR
and Hereafter brother sisters not many
people are as fortunate as us please
don't whatever you can even if it's do
not look at the amount you give but
rather look at the intention behind the
amount you give enjoy the
video no it's not actually there is more
women than men for example it depend so
what's the solution for that problem so
in America one that's the solution I'm
asking a question in in America he has
the money he can he can marry four wives
do you see the corruption in America
there is no corruption the corruption is
Western men who go around and sleep
around have side chicks mes and
girlfriend age with you look we don't
live in Disneyland there's Disneyland I
wish we can live and hold hands together
and la la back in the day was a
Christian Nation let me let me look
chrisan was illegal adultery was illegal
no you're not understand adultery is
illegal for us yeah but I'm saying it
was illegal but you're but you're not
understanding my point you're not
listening me you're not listening you're
listening to reply you're not I'm
telling you that the point is the is
that
sorry um okay yeah so my point is the
following my point is very clearly and
categorically that when it comes to
Islam Islam has a practical solution you
you you you and many people live in Four
Women is not a practical solution Al
come on okay now tell now now you have
to tell me you have to make an argument
why it's not and I will prove give you
the argument I've told you you haven't
give me an argument let me let me let me
let me let me make my argument let me
make my argument there is no 50% uh men
and 50 wom it's roughly you're talk
you're talking about birth rates the
ratio of men and women being born that's
50/50 yes I'm talking about who do more
dangerous jobs men or women men okay who
sadly involved in violence men or women
okay men so
what's even now when it comes to
degeneracy homosexuality a lot of men
are become homosexuals okay that's why
in America you have millions of
homosexual men okay so not so what when
when go to who goes to Wars men or women
men okay good so the death ratees for
these people are high now what is your
solution practical solution
for women when it comes to finding a
partner there are not enough men because
they die they in dangerous jobs and War
and many other elements what is your
solution to procreate if we came to that
point or even not even talking about a
man's nature let's go with men who die
what is your solution for that yeah so I
think if a if a obviously if a woman
can't find a husband she can't find a
husband that's it oh so she lives uh she
dies with cats no she lives with her
family or whatever okay so a woman we
say Islam says no a woman has a right
for intimacy for compassion to be taken
care of to be looked after because by
her biology she's weak she gets taken
care of by her parents by her family but
she also wants love her parents will die
so so no no no no I'm sorry are you
telling me the love of the parent is the
same with the love of the spouse of
course not so what's your solution for
this woman who she has no one to marry
so I told you the solution is she
doesn't get married that's the solution
that's a punishment that's that's that's
not Solution that's let me are you
married no do you have any woman in your
life no okay do you do you enjoy it not
particularly of course not not
particularly I don't think you enjoy it
to cuz last time I spoke to when you was
a Muslim you was talking to me about
issues with wom you didn't you didn't
have any woman in your life yeah yeah
good see and it's been years and now you
still don't have that are you in a good
place I mean it's not ideal but no no
ideal you're not in a good place at all
I can see it from your eyes you're not
in a good place at all you need and and
I'm not saying this in a in a way to
like Bel little you you need a woman in
your life yeah most people want to get
married well of course good so what I'm
saying is the following if you had the
choice believe me you'll have a couple
of
Wives come on of a headache having no no
don't try M come on you been sing for
two three years you definitely want
couple of yeah my point is the following
that woman who has no one to marry a
solution Islam gives in that scenario is
that she gets married to a man who's
already married so so deal with my point
about woman's monogamous nature women
are jealous women don't want their
manl deals with you say oh I don't care
what women feel let me give you example
let me tell if Islam tells us that we
have to go to war to defend our nation
yeah no no stick to the point Ali my
point is most women are jealous how do
you deal with do you think I'm talking
about an pineapple right
now you just giv me the reasons for for
the man now give me the reasons for the
woman how is the woman going to benefit
hear me out it's a correlation I'm not
going off topic if I talked about fruit
or something I would if the time for war
comes and mean and maybe you I told to
go to work can I come and say but I
don't like to die I don't want to die
can I say that Al I'm not talking about
War I I what I just said to you you're
not hearing me out do you want to die no
I don't do you want to die no are you
sure about that 100 okay I don't want to
die like a threat okay do I want to die
no do I want my arm blown enough no okay
need go ah good okay so when a woman
says I don't want to share my man and a
man says I don't want to go to war there
are two things that one at least you
don't die in the process this man dies
in the process you have no Islam does
not deal with feel like and I don't like
Islam listen me carefully if I go to war
I die yeah if a woman gets is her
husband gets married again she doesn't
die she's hurt so one kills you one
doesn't kill you but both of them have
no choice in the matter meaning Islam
deals with practical Solutions so if a
woman is selfish if you're talking about
feminism and there's another woman who
is single and she has to share her
husband she has to share her husband so
what I'm saying is the following we are
told in Islam things that as men we
don't like doing but we have to do it
there are things in Islam that the woman
doesn't like doing it but she has to do
it now is this exactly so what I'm
saying is your argument is fraud cuz
you're come from the liberal Paradigm
which is Pleasure and Pain I don't care
about that Paradigm because I don't live
by it I'm see from no no that is that
there that's there as well but what I'm
saying is if you look at the bigger
picture Islam deals with the communal
rights as a whole if you come and say I
want to drink alcohol Islam says no
you're not because you drinking alcohol
will harm you and you might drive a car
and Crush into people and kill them so
you cannot drink alcohol you can't come
and say but that's why are you doing
that I want to drink you are not allowed
Islam deals with a communal rights so
you should focus on Zionism because
PornHub only fans these degenerate
things that lure men like you in yes
single men who are looking to get
married and they can't what for that
reason and they go to these F only fans
ET no not you I never said you I'm
saying I'm saying men like yourself who
are single who can get LED in I'm not
saying you I didn't not say you who get
lured in who's the degenerous coming
from who are they owned by zionists they
are corrupting your youngsters your
Youth and you're here coming and saying
you muslimists jihadis my friends
zionists are destroying your youth they
are corrupting your youth lgbqt
homosexuality all this kind of stuff is
being propagated by zionists yes and I'm
very careful with my words so I'm saying
Islam is saying as Muslims we are not
allowed to ow pornography websites it is
Haram okay the Zionist is saying I don't
care they're the Gentiles I'm going to
corrupt them so who is a threat to the
Western World who's a threat to the
Western world Zionist or Muslims Zionist
and even Tommy Robinson even admitted he
said Muslims are do more for the against
when it comes to trans and all that you
know that kind of stuff yeah he himself
is
aogan said as well Muslims are the
Forefront to protect your future
generation and you're here coming to our
D table with I don't know what intention
and telling me about
Islam well they're d right you should
apologize to me you're lucky you did
that to me was patient cuz I would have
done something else yeah with all due
respect and that's if I was there if you
touched him I would have done something
else yeah so so
with all due respect so what I'm saying
is it's good that you apologize but what
I'm saying is look we're not to your
enemy we're not afet to you go and focus
on those who are look you see this
casino Place yeah go and look who owns
this yeah this is destroying houses
families they're giving people something
they want they're giving people gambling
they're giving people this is why your
worldview is flawed do you know how many
lives are Destro I watched the
documentary of a man who spent 2 million
in a matter of 9 years who he robbed
from people and took loans and you know
what was the end he said I was on the
verge of for myself in front of the
train one phone call for my brother even
me this destroys lives and we're here
talking against and you're telling me
who who hell doesn't want to drink
alcohol and eat Hulk and have sex and do
whatever the point is this is what you I
don't I don't want to I don't want to
pray for time today and learn the don't
pray don't don't pray brother Islam
doesn't need you you offering me you're
not offer my I'm offering you so much
but because you if you genuinely when
you became a Muslim I don't know if he
was a Muslim for genuinely if you
followed Islam properly my friend if
Islam I don't I don't know if he was cuz
you was all over the place the following
week you had the shoes I can prove it
I'm so sorry my friend just come in in
look I'm not saying your sh you took the
shahada look you took your shahada but
what I'm saying is the following week
you spoke to Bob and he was like yeah I
don't know I'm a bit shaky anyways it's
fine what I'm saying is Islam has a lot
to offer you but you don't have the
patience you know why cuz you live in a
system which has told you when I want a
woman I go to a prostitute when I want a
gamble I go to the Philipp Casino when I
want alcohol I go to the so you have
been programmed to I want I get this is
liberalism the the the two gods of plain
pain and pleasure so Islam say you know
my friend when I came to Islam for
example I was not allowed to have sex
outside of marriage I never drunk
alcohol anyways gambling all this kind
of stuff was it easy no it was hard but
let me tell you something my friend that
was the best thing that I ever happened
to me it be it made me who I am today it
showed me restraint it showed me
discipline it showed me principles and
guess what I am today married I am
alhamdulillah happy of course everyone
goes through ups and downs but the point
is what veryy that's you look pretty
miserable look I rather you prefer I'm
miserable I don't want some people think
I want the I prefer people think I'm
miserable yeah cuzz I don't want evil
eye yeah so my life is quite bad I'm
just saying this for the camera yeah
yeah I'm very very very I'm just saying
it for the camera so you know yeah yeah
so what I'm saying is the following I
didn't get you you'll never get it yes
my my my point is this if you came to
Islam Islam would rid you all all of
those diseases pornography do you watch
pornography or watch pornography before
I have watched pornography do you think
that's good for you do you think a grown
man masturbating the pornography is a
good thing I mean I'd rather be having
sex but well exactly there you go so
Islam has a solution for you but the
point is that you are not patient enough
to deal with that so that's why Allah
says we will test them to see the truth
from the false and sadly you failed that
test but look again there's hope you can
come back we're not stopping you we're
not saying you're doing forever but what
we're saying is my friend Islam is a
solution to the whole world don't get
caught up cuz it seems like you easily
get maneuvered you was a Zionist
flipping two months ago now I don't know
why zist I just how can you be a case
than this killing babies can you imagine
70% of men and women who with children
and women who've been killed in Gaza
children and um a woman and children I I
already told him why that was my friend
do you know how cold do I tell something
you have to be a maniac to believe that
you have to be I'm do you know why
they're dying because they're
brainwashed by Islam that's why you are
psychologically
Disturbed noral I saw a video saw video
you not noral my friend this was during
the comment in the early stages noral
the guy was saying us and do you know
what the guy said to him he said brother
this this is Jihad you're not normal man
I swear to God
kind of I'm going to I'll make a simple
argument for you they'd rather live in a
tunnel live in some filthy tunnel
underground you house then just
surrender to the Israelis why why would
they want to why would they want to do
that to their families do that to
themselves those tunel they're
brainwashed who built those tunnels I
don't know who buil well then why you
making the AL of the tunnel the isra
aded they built who would rather live
Israel CNN they admitted they built
those tunnels why they built those
tunnels because they just wanted to
increase the land or whatever the case
may be then they started moaning when
Hamas started utilizing those tunnels
and extending those tunnels did so you
didn't know that but with respect
shishan that has nothing to do with my
point no it does because you're saying
that they willing to live under those
tunnels and then but I'm telling you
that the people that have created those
tunnels forced them into those tunnels
are Israel is to do with your point
secondly force them to fight they could
have just surr second he said he said
women and children said women and
children your response was because they
believe in Islam so according to you
they brainwashed by Islam ACC if
according to you a child yeah believes
in Islam very very sorry for any
children that have died but it is their
parents' fault because they have brought
them up I haven't I haven't finished my
point yet a child theyd rather die if a
child one second one second you got
plenty of time if a child believes in
Islam and they live in Gaza you're
saying it's okay to blow them to Sam no
I am not saying that that was the arum
that you made their parents are at fault
for bringing them up with a backwards so
it's okay toed religion so it's okay to
blow them let me ask you one question
let me tell something you're going to
make yourself look very stupid now okay
very stupid and I'm going to call you an
islamist after yeah cuz your argument is
that them defending theel makes them
islamist yeah no no that wasn't my
argument okay one second simple question
my argument was it's very sad that
children and innocent people are being
killed and why are they being killed
because they're brainwashed by Islam and
what does Islam say about cuz you said
they're brainwashed by Islam brainwashed
to do to do what so they're brainwashed
by Islam to hate the you call you call
them zionists really they're called Jews
just so you know okay they brainwashed
to hate Jews and they'd rather be killed
than surrender okay where where Islam
does it say hate
Jews oh well it says that in every
single
Quran every single that's that's what I
said go and open go and open I got a
free Quran for you come on come
on I'm not going to find it you you know
very you're not going to find it not
because you're not looking because it
doesn't exist okay I'm ask it does say
to okay can you show me
please it says take Chris as your as
your where where where does say you got
the worldwide multiple I'm not going to
find it you can't everyone who watches
this video talking do you think look I'm
I'm I'm in the public sphere people kind
of know me do you think I'm stupid
enough to make a statement I'm going to
get deun for do you think I'm that dumb
where does it say that we should hate
juice so might not
specific don't take them as friends so
do you see look we're going to now you
Adit it says don't take them as friends
I'm going to check are you brainwashed
or the children in children Gaza look
you said the children in Gaza are
brainwashed I'm proving now that you are
brainwashed I just proved it now number
one you made a statement that you don't
know number two who's the legend thean
is already here come on okay now Point
number two first point you made is you
don't even know you're talking out of
ignorance that means you are brainwashed
if you was brainwash listen if you was
not brainwash you would not make a
statement that does not exist number two
the prophet's wife was an ethnically Jew
she was ethnically Jew she was after he
killed all her family uh who's her
family her her husband and her father
who was waging waren Allah his messenger
yes so excuse me if somebody trying to
you my point is this we we are not told
to hate the juice that's a lie so you're
being brainwashed number two no we don't
you can fact check me you you call them
zionists the truth is they're Jews fact
check me so you're saying every Zionist
is a Jew
no okay is Isis Muslims clearly there's
a distinction between they think they're
Muslims yeah so good so there are good
and bad Muslims yeah okay so there are
Zionist Jews and there are Jews that are
not Zionist would you accept that yeah
thank you so again proven you been
brainwash second time prove argument
number three if I come to you and say
you just hate the Jews who want to have
their own country listen to me take your
jacket one second one second take your
jacket off give me a jacket give me a
jacket give me a jacket would you defend
okay thank you what you done there was
this man is supp trying to take my
jacket okay you said are you okay Ali
the next moveie you would right because
you didn't give him your jacket you're
an
Islam now now if I forced myself and
said I'm going to take your jacket off
you have a right to push me and say Ali
you are invading my space you are taking
an item that belongs to me and if I said
this bloody terrorist look at him and
this is me taking your jacket now if I
came to your house and killed your mom
and dad bang bang and I said to you
you're going to live in the toilet now I
own this house are you brainwashed to
defend yourself is not the right analogy
are you brainwashing defend yourself I'm
not giving analogy I'm Palestinians I'm
not talking about Palestinians I'm not
talking I'm giving an don't care I'm not
talking about Palestinians or I'm just
saying analogy I come and kill your mom
and dad bang bang I say to you you're
going to live in the toilet from now on
and I'm going to see here and now I'll
give you some crumbs are you brainwash
islamist terrorist whatever you want to
call it if you defend yourself and take
back your house no thank you very much
but that's what you doing that's what
you lot have been it's been emotional
you have been now I now I need now I
need to do some
some David David to the Islam you mean
da I like nice see you just talk
nonsense when you when when you lose the
AR he he beat me really bad guys next
time I'm going to train
harder anyways let's do something how
many people watch you're a terrorist
thank you very much alhamdulillah